my destiny is to rule all others on
November 3rd baronial time experience
the film critics call a majestic
spectacle it's a triumph mascot is not a
place it's a people the boldest Marvel
film yet now those who need your help
shall we after you
hey everybody so I've already posted my
non-spoilery thor ragnarok review in the
movie hasn't quite come out yet but I
wanted to talk a little bit about Marvel
phase 4 in address a little bit about
what's going on with the Thor character
in predictions for after infinity war
because I do think that Chris Hemsworth
will resize a new contract his Marvel
movie contract is coming to an end
through infinity war he like Chris Evans
and a couple other people are reaching
the end of their contract so a lot of
people are wondering what's going on
next and they've been teasing some stuff
for behind the scenes Kevin Feige has
already confirmed a few things without
giving away too many big spoilers so
I'll say there's a new round of the Thor
take a giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber or leave a
comment on this video the couple of bits
of footage you see in that are like the
first real public appearance of Odin
that we've seen in the movie and I don't
want to talk about him too much because
that kind of gets into spoilers and I
will post a spoilery easter egg video
when the movie comes out in theaters in
the United States but his line of
dialogue Asgard isn't a place it's a
people sort of gives you an idea for
where the Thor character is headed in
the future of the movies obviously we
still have all this infinity war
craziness the Infinity Gauntlet Thanos
that's all sort of predetermined but
after that I believe the future of Thor
is in the future of the Iron Man
character so think about what happened
to Iron Man after he got his trilogy and
then there's the really cool Donald
Blake twist from the comics where for a
period of time he was Donald Blake
walking around as a man who wasn't
totally sure that he was Thor but the
hammer had been changed into a stick so
that when he smashed it down he would
become Thor instantly it would change
his appearance so just a really big wink
at that adjust in the way that they're
winking a lot of Jack Kirby a lot of
Walt Simonson
Serdar saga stuff during the movie this
is Thor's third movie and even though
they've been teasing that the director
is going to do another Marvel movie
eventually the way people are writing
about it they're interpreting that is
the fact that there will be another Thor
movie in the future and while there will
be a lot of Thor stuff happening in the
MCU really the bigger thing that's being
rolled out in phase 4 is brand-new
characters that you haven't seen before
new locations and it's a lot harder to
do that when you have a Thor character
that's tied to Asgard and all these
characters that have come
back in the last three movies so one of
the cool ideas of ragnarok is that
they're sort of deconstructing the idea
of how they make movies they've kind of
done that with the phase three movies in
general like when you saw guardians of
the galaxy - or spider-man homecoming
those movies are connected to the MCU
but they're not nearly as overlapping as
previous phase one phase two films were
so really the true value is in these
characters not so much in doing sequels
to movies that nobody asked for really
the smart thing for Marvel to do and
they've already started to do this is
just go to different places that we've
never seen before in black panther's
probably the best example of that so if
you're really happy with the way Marvel
is just completely changing their
formula and bringing you really amazing
movies and really unchaining some of
these characters you have James Gunn in
that first guardians of the galaxy movie
to think because they let it be super
weird it was a small budget but people
showed up big time for it so they're
like oh okay we can actually make weird
movies we don't have to do this cookie
cutter thing where we just pump these
sequels out over and over even Robert
Downey jr. has said that nobody wants
the Iron Man for that people think that
they want like oh yeah we want another
Iron Man movie but he's like people
don't want that as much as you think
that they want that they want the Iron
Man character doing something really
badass which is where you get to things
like spider-man homecoming and even part
of the charm of thor ragnarok is the
idea that it's also a big Hulk movie -
even though it's a Thor narrative you
have a lot of hook in there so the
future of Marvel is really in these mini
crossover more self-contained style
movies and then you still have your big
Avengers movies where everybody comes
together but you don't necessarily need
to chain them all to a specific
MacGuffin think about how much the
Infinity Gauntlet in the gems played
into phase 1 and phase 2 and how much of
that have we seen in phase 3 so far very
little so when we get to phase 4 and
they tea up the new makeup and like it
won't be just another Infinity Gauntlet
saga it'll be something else they won't
be quite so slavish to it in every
single movie as much as they were in
phase one and Phase two but I feel like
it's not spoilery to say that the Thor
character will be around for a long time
as long as Chris Hemsworth keeps wanting
to come back so without talking about
the plot of the end of the
movie they sort of engineer away for
Thor to do the Robert Downey jr. thing
where he can keep coming back in all
these movies but you don't have to do it
in Thor 4 but they could do the for Thor
movie if they want to really what I
think that they'll do is you'll see Thor
in space doing guardians of the galaxy
adjacent things because if you haven't
seen my non-spoilery review yet I talked
a little bit about the dynamics of the
character and just how well he works
when you let him leave the earth and
Asgard let him roam around in space
space Thor guest-starring in other
people's movies will be one of the most
fun things that they could do with the
character so it should come as no
surprise that that's why they use him is
the connective tissue to infinity war in
that comic-con trailer that they
released where he faced plants on the
Milano
so one Chris Hemsworth is just hilarious
but because he's so powerful you just
need to present him with challenges that
you might not find on earth that's
better for people like spider-man like
the ground level Avengers
he's very powerful he's still an a-list
Avenger but Thor is a genuine God in the
Marvel Universe so you just need to up
the threat level accordingly although
they did confirm that another a list
avenger who's not Iron Man will get star
in the next spider-man solo film that'll
take place directly after Avengers 4 so
on that list honestly I think that the
Hulk is probably the best option like if
he comes back to earth because part of
the sharing arrangement with the Spider
Man Sony deal is that they get access to
the Avengers characters and they want
the really familiar ones so like Captain
Marvel is gonna be an awesome character
but people aren't super familiar with
her even though she's gonna be a super
powerful she'll be really awesome in
that fourth Avengers film but honestly
when you're looking for a list Avengers
that are really recognizable and
bankable you're looking at people like
Hulk Captain America Thor Iron Man those
are the people that Sony really wants
and because there's such a comedic tone
to spider-man movies Hulk just works
really well with that so that's why I'm
actually picking Hulk over Captain
America although you guys can let me
know what you think in the comments
below who do you want to guest star in
the next spider-man movie assuming that
Thor is freed up to roam around to other
people's movies do you want to see him
in outer space do you want to see him in
the next
spider-man movie I feel like Thor could
be really funny in that but it would be
really weird seeing him pal around town
with Peter Parker with his crazy power
levels but they haven't officially said
what's going on with the space-based
movies in phase four only the James Gunn
is helping spearhead a lot of those
ideas they'll introduce a lot of new
characters like you have Adam warlock
probably the biggest new character that
they've teased is coming it is sort of
changing of the roster of the guardians
of the galaxy like they'll still be
guardians movies but it'll be a
different roster after guardians vol 3
so that is why I think the Thor would
actually work really well in that
franchise if they want to make him one
of the guardians of the galaxy but I
almost forgot Kevin Feige also responded
to a lot of female Thor questions like
would we ever see a female Thor honestly
if they're gonna do that I think that
they would just turn Valkyrie into the
next door because Tessa Thompson is so
awesome during Thor Ragnarok you're like
why wouldn't they just do that it'd be a
no-brainer she's already a badass and
almost as powerful as Thor but if you
know the comic book twist behind female
Thor it's a little bit different in the
comics are actually bringing back the
regular version of Thor he has a gold
hammer it's super blinged out I don't
know what the twist is going to be but
that has nothing to do with what's going
on in the movies that's all comic book
stuff so it's completely separate but
what will happen next is is tomorrow's
flash day so there'll be a whole bunch
of flash posting there's some new Rick
and Morty if I have time then I'll get
that out if not that'll be Wednesday but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jay ready please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details you can
click here for my non-spoilery thor
ragnarok review and you can click here
for a brand new Justice League trailer
with a whole bunch of Superman DS phrase
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys